Oh
I think we need to get away from the
idea of leaving this to a small and
heroic band of radio astronomers and try
and spread the burden across the entire
scientific community I think all the
sciences can contribute and I'll give
you some examples one of the things
that's baffling about ET and this is an
idea that goes back to Enrico Fermi at
the end of the Second World War is why
haven't they did civilizations spread
across the galaxy and colonized it or
the very least visited what why where is
everybody is the way Fermi put it and so
he took that as evidence so there's
nobody out there the fact that that
earth has not been visited or colonized
that the aliens haven't come here a long
time ago
is evidence that they're not out there
either but I think I could put a spin on
this particular story and say well how
do we know the aliens didn't come and it
doesn't have to be flesh and blood
aliens literally stepping out of a
spacecraft it could be their machines or
their probes or robots or something of
that sort that they could well have come
a very long time ago and in this game
you've got a thing not in thousands or
even millions of years but hundreds of
millions or billions of years so it's
that sort of timescale we have to think
on and the question is would any trace
remain of alien activity say in our
solar system after that's like a figure
out of midair or 100 million years you
came back in another 100 million years
from now would any trace of human human
activity remain the answer is not very
much but there are some things that we
could look for if he did pass through
the solar system obviously didn't didn't
stop for a hundred million years what we
find well there are some things like
nuclear waste if you dump nuclear waste
that will certainly survive for that
length of time we could go look for that
any sort of large-scale mining or
querying activities would leave scars
that although there might be buried
beneath rock strata would still be be
discernible to a geologist doing a
survey we could look for that too and
then there's one other idea that's crazy
but it's dear to my heart and this
inspector the message in the bottle
concepts so up to now Sethi has been
involved in looking for messages that
are being deliberately beamed at us and
as I've explained that's pretty unlikely
but there's another type of messaging of
which the beacon is an example it's a
one-way message when you put a message
in a bottle and throw it into the sea
you don't think to yourself well I
expect a reply it's you don't know if
anybody's ever going to find it and
certainly don't know who's going to find
it so it's just sort of left to its own
devices well in the same way we might
imagine that an alien civilization might
have put a message in a bottle for
anyone who might find it and and those
that anyone could be asked could be
human beings so where is the bottle and
where is the message whether I'm open to
suggestions from one idea I've had is
that maybe the bottle are living cells
to rest really organisms and that the
message is encoded in DNA viruses are
continually infecting organisms on earth
and uploading their DNA into the genomes
of those organisms so there's a well
understood pathway for getting
information into DNA and we're littered
with in our own genomes have got huge
amounts of this junk that so climbed on
board from viruses over evolutionary
history so if viruses can do it et can
do it and it seems to me that we we
could in addition to scouring the skies
for radio waves with the message encoded
we could scour terrestrial genomes which
are being sequenced anyway to see if
there's a message from ET encoded in it
you know could be some striking string
of nucleotide bases the famous a
four-letter alphabet that is the
language of life the A's Jesus sees and
T's in the DNA might just spell out some
sort of message that would attract our
attention now of course this is a crazy
idea I'm not actually suggesting that
there really is a message from ET in
gene and what I'm saying is that's the
type of thinking we need and maybe it's
no more crazy than expecting it to be
etched into radio waves coming from the
sky